you workshop
so our first speaker will be max welling
who will be discussing variant
reinforcement learning
let's take it away
all right thank you
um
okay
can you see the
the full screen now yes
looks good okay how much time do i have
again
for this an hour
a full hour including questions that is
right okay
all right um yeah so i probably don't
need an hour um
so this is the first time i give this
talk
so uh
might be not as smooth as usual
it's also quite exciting to talk about
something new
so i'm going to talk about equivariant
rl i try to fit it into the theme of the
workshop which is a
optimization and equivariance
and so this is work with um
these folks here
in particular elise van der paul
so here she is
um we have written a couple of papers
and she has been the driving force
behind all of this she is
almost graduating so on the job market
if you're interested in and with
these three wonderful collaborators as
well
so i'll start with a
very brief introduction in reinforcement
learning
then i'll comment a little bit about you
know what reinforcement learning really
has to do with optimization
then i'll talk about
markov decision processes homomorphisms
and their relation to equivariance
and then i'll talk about equivalent
multi-agent systems and this is
a picture made and there's another one
coming from by maurice wyler
about
equivarian deep learning on manifolds
and sphere in this case um not quite
related necessarily to this talk
okay so uh what is reinforcement
learning so reinforcement learning we
have um basically
an agent
and we have a world
and the agent can act on the world can
do things in the world
and it can observe the state
as well as a reward from the world
and so typically learning is by trial
and error so you
have a sort of a starting policy you try
things you get you collect rewards and
then you iteratively improve yourself
um so in more detail so we have a policy
pie for the
for the
reagent
depending on the state the agent is in
so in this talk we'll only look at fully
observable markov statistic processes
and the policy is basically a function
that maps the state to an action so the
action is then applied to the real world
and then the real world um under the
action and given its current state will
then transition to a new state
uh could be stochastically but also
deterministically
and then there's a reward that gets
collected at that time
depending on both the state as well as
the
action that's being taken and that's
recorded as r at that time
um so those two numbers are then being
you know under full observability and
then being pro you know fed back into
the agent
who will then use that to update the
policy
and choose new action and in the end of
course the agent would like to
maximize
the total future reward
not just the instantaneous reward
so as are states air actions tier
transition functions rs to reward
function
and pi is the policy and as i said the
goal
is to maximize the cumulative future
reward not just the instantaneous reward
okay so what is the relationship
between reinforcement learning and
optimization
so there is a recent
update in the number of papers that are
trying to use reinforcement learning
to um improve
optimization algorithms and the idea is
that
you can sort of amortize
um
over different optimization problems
that is you can sort of look at the
patterns that algorithms use to solve
certain problems
and then
and you know encode those into a policy
which could then help you solve the
problem faster next time
so we have ourselves worked on something
like
vehicle routing problems and dsp
the traveling salesman's problem is this
subset of those
basically by having some kind of graph
neural network
that feeds in the state
the current state of the
of the tsp problem you want to solve
and then predicts the next action to
take which gets which which is the next
visit the city that you want to visit
to solve the problem
here's another paper
um and here the driver max we have a
question really quick yeah oh sure yeah
but could you get back to
cumulative reward what is that a limit
of arithmetic averages or some with
discounting factor
yeah so so um will you define it could
you is there formula for that reward
no so there is of course a formula but
uh the
basically what i'm going to talk about
today is sort of
independent of what you choose there of
course you could just use a discounted
cumulative reward
you could choose a finite horizon reward
you could put anything you want there
um
but basically what i'm going to talk
about
works
for whatever you choose for your future
cumulative report
is that okay i can't see anybody so uh
okay
if you if you don't agree then
you can say so
okay so uh so so this is uh being driven
by um this student dr cole has been
publishing on this particular problem
but we haven't really used
um
any sort of aqua variants here although
it seems like a very good idea to do it
right because clearly
solving a vehicle routing problem or a
tsp problem doesn't depend on how you
orient the problem right if you
rotate the problem you rotate the world
by 90 degrees
then you would want the same solution
out and this neural network for instance
wasn't really equivariant didn't inc you
know didn't have that particular
symmetry
in you know encoded in in its uh sort of
operations
so that's something that we can still do
but we haven't done yet but this at
least you know lays bare that there is
an interesting relationship between
reinforcement running and optimization
in fact more recently
um
google has written a paper where they
use reinforcement learning to do chip
design optimization so putting down
all the
you know the memory blocks and the sort
of
standard cells
onto a canvas such that certain
objectives are
optimized like minimum area
yet the wire length should be minimal
and stuff like that so that's a clear
optimization problem
and they've shown that by using
reinforcement learning
you can learn from previous iterations
of solving their problem and and do
better next time
now reinforcement running is known known
to be
very data-hungry
um and so here's a couple of examples of
you know i don't know number of samples
or observations that you need in order
to train your policy
and what we're going to try to do today
is to use the fact that
in fact the world has certain symmetries
and that can be used to reduce
the number of data points for learning
so in other words you can learn faster
with fewer observations with the real
world
but basically
noticing that if you have an action
in a world
in a certain situation and you could map
that to another situation
that seemingly looks different
but you can have an easy transformation
on your action or your policy
which still
would obviously under the symmetry give
you
you know the same result or you know if
it's optimal that also the optimal
result
right so here's a couple of examples so
if you change the coloring scheme
of your input your chessboard or
whatever
game board
now clearly you don't want the
you know the policy to be to depend on
that
or if you learn a car to drive
in uh sort of in england people drive on
the left-hand side of the road and in
amsterdam and in europe
drive on the right-hand side of the road
you can imagine that there is a mapping
between the optimal policy for driving
on the left-hand side of the road and
the optimal policy driving on the
right-hand side of the road so that once
you have learned
to drive on the right-hand side of the
road
you can then in one go
transform everything to a car that
drives on the left-hand side of the road
and so you don't have to
learn everything from start again
and then of course you can rotate
things right if you have a task you pick
out let's say the phone
might be your task
you know you want that task to be
independent of the orientation in which
you know not independent but you know
equivalent as we say of the orientation
in which the task is being presented to
use in other words you still want to
pick up the phone where the action is
here at the bottom left you can
transform that action if you know how
the world is rotated to the left upper
corner
and this one is is a pole and some of
the balancing pole um and we see
examples
about this so basically you know if if
you're balancing
stick is like this you know you need to
push the car to the right in order to
balance the pool the pole and of course
if you reflect that situation
um
then you know here you would have to
push to the left
um in order to balance the pole and so
there again there is a symmetry between
these two situations
so we're going to use
uh this concept of a group
um to reduce the number of
transformations that we're going to
consider i think
the theory that we developed here is
actually more general you can also think
about other sets of transformations
maybe semi groups or other types of
group or other types of transformations
but to make our life easy
in this first sort of
setting we're going to look at
groups we have of course certain
properties
like there there's an identity map
there's an it's invertible
there's closure and there's
associativity
and
so
a couple of examples are translation
reflection and rotation
now
what what would this these you know
these groups and symmetries how would
they work in reinforcement so we have
been working a lot on
incorporating symmetries
in deep learning so training neural
networks that transform in certain ways
or their predictions are invariant under
certain transformations on the input
or equivariant let's say in the case so
invariant if you do classification
equivalent let's say if you do
segmentation so you want the
segmentation map to rotate if you wrote
you know with the rotation of the input
image
but what does it mean for reinforcement
learning so that's the question that we
were asking ourselves here
so in the reinforcement of course the
mdp is defined by
a reward function
and a
sort of transition function
and what we're going to say is that we
want the reward function to be invariant
under the action of the group
on the state and the action space right
so in this case let's say
you know um there could be a symmetry
here and the reward of being an in a
should be the same as the reward in
being in b if you want to go to the goal
because this the situation is exactly
symmetric
um in the same at the same time there's
something similar for the transition
probability
where if you apply
you know the transformation to the to
the input state and the action space
then there is there is also the same
transformation on the transition step to
this this the state where you're going
to transition in
and then you want this type of
invariance uh to happen right so in
other words
this path of going left and then should
we have the same total reward as this
path which is a similar path but in this
case you go up and right in this case
you go right and up
so there's this transformation between
the two
now people often talk about
homomorphisms and we'll talk about that
too and the idea is that really you can
map this situation on an equivalent
situation
by equating a and b to be the same state
so in other words you just cut this two
thing in two and you map all the states
on the left you map it on the states to
the right because once you know what to
do here you also know what to do here so
you can sort of half your space and you
can just reason in this space so we got
a mapping
you know subjective mapping down to a
lower dimensional space
uh injected mapping
um
yeah max
yeah is it like the states in the
actions they say the same set
so you you you apply the same group to
the states and and actions yeah that's a
great question um but yeah the answer is
no so
um and i'll i'll get to that in a minute
so for instance it's it's a wrong
formula there
yeah it's true so this g here
it's it's it's it's sort of a
if i say ga i mean the action of the
group element g on a which could be
which could take a different form
as the action of
you know the group element g on s so
this could be a matrix that is quite
different from this matrix right so it's
so the the equations here are not in
that sense super precise but they mean
the action of this group element on this
action which could actually be different
than this one
but that's a good question
yeah
um
so uh
yeah so we're going to say that s a and
gsga are symmetric state action pairs
and they have the same policy piece by
star that's also an imprecise statement
they don't have the same policy by start
they have
you know the same policy up to a
transformation and we'll see that in
more detail
okay so
then
in equivariance so what do we mean by
equivalent maps
um so if we have some input space the
space of images of dogs
and we want to map to some let's say
maybe a segmentation map
of dogs
then you know f is the segmentation map
so goes to a different space let's say
you know binary numbers an image with
binary numbers in them
if i rotate the input image
i of course i'm going to end up with a
different segmentation map
but that segmentation map should be the
rotate rotation of this segmentation map
so we have a g here we have a g prime
here that can be different
and we want the closure of this kind of
diagram we want that
first applying the segmentation map and
then rotating in segmentation space
or first rotating the input image and
then applying the segmentation should
end up at the same point
or you can sort of here is
first f x and g prime equals g x f
now the special case of this
is invariance
so when you are invariant um it
basically means that
the the orbit which is all the
transformations
you apply to the input map is all mapped
to the same point here so you could
think of this as a classification
problem where you want to classify this
as a dog
then of course all rotated dogs are
still dogs so they map to the same point
and so invariance is given by this
equation
and
again this is this is a special case of
the agri variants uh case
so max has to understand the
quantification in your previous slide uh
so uh
yeah sorry let me actually so i can see
people i think that's better yeah all
right
i just wanted to understand the
quantification in your previous slide uh
this one so this is uh um
so for all g there exists some g prime
is that the equivariance thing or yeah
so certainly so
for all g
there there exists a a single g prime
that that would uh be the operation
on f
um and so this is this is
yeah so it's a constraint on f
if you want right so g and g prime are
fixed
and this this means that the map f is
constrained
shouldn't there be a group
should there be a group action in the
image space as well
yeah that's that's this one right g
times x is the there's the group action
in the image space oh i mean oh i see
sorry i mean in the sense of functions
like in the that's in the domain
and in the range that's where uh g prime
will act at
really it's like
at just a different action of g
it's different right so here we actually
properly said it was different it's g
prime i mean i i think i've misjudged my
audience because i think i'm talking to
mathematicians and i really have to
apologize for
sloppy notation
i hope you don't uh
i i you you can you can look through it
i mean this is meant
to be sort of a high level
understandable you know for
non-mathematicians presentation but it's
also it's also sloppy right so that's
that's a product
sorry would be great to present that as
a as a product of matrices example of
this situation yeah yeah absolutely so
you you should think of this as matrices
right you should really think of x as a
you know as a as the image pixels
written out as a long vector
huh
yes yes
yeah so think of it as matrices i think
that's that's the so that's the easiest
way to think about this
okay so um
the advantages of equivariance when we
develop them so this is not when we
started develop these things in 2016
um
we wanted to develop them for a deep
neural network so it was just for maps
you know
predictions classifications you know all
these kinds of things
and we
we did it for euclidean spaces but for
the mathematicians maybe it's also
interesting
to note that we also did it for
arbitrary manifold so we can actually
define
convolutions for arbitrary manifolds and
that actually gets into very interesting
math because it's fiber bundles and
stuff like that so you can read about it
and this uh you know maurice weiler
wrote a 200 page document that's much
more mathematical on this topic and taco
cohen
his thesis is also very mathematical in
his respect so
i think that would be a nice sort of
reference
to look at the mathematics of all of
this but there is very clean nice
mathematics behind this
as i said so what we want from
equivariance is this closing of this
diagram which is
first transforming
let's say under a symmetry operation
this case rotation over the z-axis
and then
doing the filtering which is like your
convolution
in this case it's some kind of filter
that's an edge detector
should be the same as first filtering
and then doing the the symmetry
transformation in this new space so
again
this should be phi prime not phi
because this could in fact i'll show an
example in a minute be a different
operation than this and i'll have an
example in a minute
um
what this does is so this puts
additional structure
on the space of representations that you
create
right where you're filtering you know i
hope you know about deep learning
um that
will give you filter maps they organize
themselves in capsules what we call
capsules
and i'll talk about more in a minute but
under transformations of the input
you'll get very nice transformations
in the sort of representation space
which means that the
representation states become much more
structured and and again that's also for
the next layer
more easy to detect patterns against
also for sort of recursive learning
where the next layer needs to learn
you know patterns of the previous layer
putting the structure in there actually
does help a lot
um perhaps the most important part or as
i said another um
interesting property of these capsules
is that they separate
the presence of an object and the sort
of pose of that object
so these capsules they have a beautiful
interpretation as if you look at the
total activation of this capsule
uh which is you know the
hidden units or the latent units that
are in this in this particular
um
sort of capsule if you if you add up all
the activations
absolute value let's say you'll you
you'll code for whether there is
that that object is present
now
if you actually change the input if you
transform the input you change the pose
of the object which means that you have
some internal
transformation happening
in this capsule
keeping the total activation constant so
the norm stays constant but you'll sort
of change the phase or the sort of
activation pattern inside
and that we call often pose and that's
actually quite related to how the brain
also decomposes presence and pose of
objects
but the most important part for this for
learning is that this particular trick
helps you reduce the number of
parameters in your neural network
because it basically is constrained the
this cons this this is a constraint on k
the filter
will reduce the number of independent
parameters that are in this kernel k
um
it's similar to
if you have a mlp a multi-layer
perceptron which is a fully connected
neural network there's there's a lot of
parameters because there's you know n
squared parameters where n is the number
of neurons
but if you make that if you exploit
translation equivariance you you turn
that into a convolution
and then the only set of parameters that
is left is the
parameters of the convolution kernel
which could be as small as nine
right so you go from n squared to nine
and uh and and so
and here you know if you keep on going
not just translations but you also do
rotations
then the number of parameters is further
reduced with the advantage that you can
learn faster from
little less data
okay so then here is more explanation of
what this equivariant convolution
is and indeed that the operator
that is in the sort of space after the
mapping can actually be different
from the operator in your original space
so here is mona lisa and this is a sort
of in the input space
a rotation of the mona lisa right so the
pixels are just being rotated
now here is
let's say our convolution
and the convolution
um in this case consists let's say of
four of two detectors there's an eye
detector and there's a mouse detector
and so
you'll get two detections here on the
eyes and one here on the mouse
but
um and to turn this into an acquivariant
convolution what we will do is we will
copy
the the filter
four times
over the four
90 degree angle rotations
and so we get a capsule with four
elements in them four feature maps here
for both the eye capsule and the mouth
capsule
so now how to close the diagram if i
rotate and then filter it should be the
same as if i first
filter and rotate
now what happens if i rotate and then
filter well i can see what happens
because
i now the eye detectors
that are rotated get activated
and so i get two detections here
and one mouth detection here of course
all the other ones are out of
orientation so they don't fire
but and here you see that the the
detections rotate
and the feature map
permutes cyclically to the right so now
the operation here
that's happening in the latent space
is not just a rotation of the feature
map
it is also a cyclic permutation
in the capsule dimension and this is the
capsule dimension
so that's you know the best i can do in
sort of explaining
what uh you know in a non-mathematical
manner perhaps what the
equivariance
operation and the abstract space looks
like and these sort of filtered space
look like so max i have a question uh
about this slide so the group that
emerges in this on the right hand side
is a discrete group and this seems to be
depending on
um what the means on the left-hand side
is just a rotation group of i mean i
guess that's what 90 degrees rotation
only 90 degrees yeah so yeah okay so i
see what you're saying so so this can
all be generalized to continuous
rotations
right
and then you know this looks clearly
different
and so instead of having
you know sort of the um
so the the four or 90 degrees rotations
you'll then have to use irreducible
representations of the group so it's
much more like you know spherical
harmonics or something like that and you
cut that off at sort of a frequency so
you say let you know either you take an
infinite set of feature maps but it's a
bit too many so you'll just take the low
frequencies of the spherical harmonics
or you know the so2 rotations right
which are just uh discrete numbers m
and um and you cut it off to keep a
finite dimension for your capsule
um and then you'll have equivalence
under
um any rotation angle and not just the
rotation angle uh given by 90 degrees
but this is just for
you know for simplicity
and practice what would you do i mean
from a practitioner's point of view yeah
that's it
yeah it's a great question because
there's advantages to both um
so it turns out that if you do a pretty
fine
uh sort of discretization of this group
it has the advantage that i mean the
disadvantage of course that it's
approximate in that sense um
the advantages is that you also have to
use a non-linearity after this and the
non-linearity has to be um
equivalent as well it has to maintain
active variance
and in this particular representation
you can use
basically a point-wise non-linearity
if you if you apply the same
non-linearity at every pixel it will
work
however if you do this in this kind of
sort of fourier space
and the error you know the the
irreducible representation space
the the non-linearities that you have
are much less varied in the way that for
instance you can take the norm
and take an arbitrary norm function of
the norm
of the
you know of the vector of activations
but that's about it because otherwise
you will break equivariance and so that
actually hurts performance quite a bit
so it's um in fact
it it's the jury is still out a bit and
i would expect you know it's clearly
a lot nicer mathematically to use the
irreducible representations
but there is this practicality about
non-linearities which make it in
practice actually that this might work
better
thank you
okay all right max can i also ask a
question on the input side um i guess um
i mean these rotations by 90 degree you
can present exactly and if you have
general rotations then
do you do the same thing there like you
have your input image you decompose it
and some you know finite number of
fourier modes so that you then can
rotate exactly on the input or are you
treating the group elements as being
some approximate actions
no um
so what you do is um
you you don't have to
decompose the input in terms of uh
of fourier elements you just can take
the actual pixel input but the kernel
that you use
to transform to the next layer that
kernel
now has to be in you know has to set you
know has to map to an irreducible
representation yeah and that equilibrium
still makes sense of course yeah yeah
thanks
okay so the next uh thing is
probably ridiculous to explain to you um
because you know much more about this
than i do
but let me at least state
this idea of a homomorphism you know so
it's basically a map right where um you
take two
an x and a y in an input space that has
a certain product
and you then apply a map f
in such a way that you also have an
operation in this in this new space f
and and and such that this equation
holds
and of course you can do you know linear
maps and maps to exponential functions
but the most
important one here are the group
representations which is you know a
well-known homomorphism which is if i
take two group elements and i multiply
them
and then take the let's say matrix
representation of the
um of the you know group element that
comes out of that
it should be the same as you know first
taking the matrix of g1 and then the
matrix of g2 and then do matrix
multiplication of these two
um sort of representations at these two
matrices
these two representations
so this is so here here we go from sort
of an abstract group element to the
actual matrices and we indicate that
with rho but we'll be sloppy about it
and if we say g
apply to x then we actually do mean a
matrix representation
okay so now let's go to um how you know
and this is known so uh you know there
is this particular for instance this
particular reference here
so um it's known that there is uh so
that sometimes um there is these
homomorphisms in mdps which basically
mean
that there is some kind of symmetry in
this space
so so let's say this is our input space
it's like a pole balancing task
the space consists of states and actions
and this particular point here is
the pole is you know falling to the to
the left
um and the card
is moving to the right which makes it
worse i guess um so you you could you
could think the card needs to move to
the left um in order to balance this
thing
now on the other side if you do a flip
around the origin
then there is another
state action pair
that is
mirrored
and that has uh the same
you know reward
and the same and it has sort of a you
know
a transformed transition function so if
i know what to do here
i know precisely what to do here i need
to transform the state the action and
the next state right
and so there's a whole bunch of these
things
so what we go so and what we're going to
say is now that you know we have an
orbit
of the group which applied to a
particular state that goes through all
of these elements
which are sort of related to each other
under this symmetry it is state action
space
and what we can do now is under mdp
homomorphism is map them into a smaller
space
an abstract space if you want
where we're only going to retain one
copy so it's kind of an equivalence
class now so you're just looking at the
equivalence class of states where the
equivalence class is the orbit of the
group
we call this s bar and a bar
and we're now just going to reason this
space so every time i'm sort of moving
here and then i'm moving here
now all of these things can be mapped
onto each other and i'm sort of
using
less data to learn my policy because i'm
just saying that these two policies
should be related to each other you know
through this symmetry
um and it's sort of this this connection
with equivariance that is kind of new in
this story
um yeah so i said this right so there's
a symmetric actions pair they sort of
result in the same policy by star but i
mean by that actually one is a
transformed policy of the other one
okay so um something like that
relates to um
also what we did in neural networks and
deep neural networks
so in a deep neural network let's say i
have an input image
and i have a symmetry transformation
says rotation so i have this orbit here
and i have another guy here which is uh
not on the same orbit is another orbit
if i have some kind of homomorphism that
maps that say these two things to the
same abstract
uh sort of icon of an of a face
then
if i move along this orbit
and i map do the mapping from here i get
to a rotated copy
of this sort of abstract representation
of these faces
and it's this equivariance which
maintains this nice property that this
actually happens so that this phase is
not mapping to some other attract space
and you can think of this maybe in this
example as the policy that is changing
and this is the sort of input state
pair
um okay so let's um
so let's look at certain problems and
let's connect the sort of the two
issues of mdp hormone morphism with
um the the equivariance so here's a
couple of examples that we looked at for
instance ball balancing and this is a
as a
you know
the cross needs to catch the uh
you know this particular thing so uh
you know i know this is symmetric under
rotations of 90 degrees
so they need to it needs to go on top of
it to get to catch it or something like
this
and and here is a pole
which you know you can move this thing
up and down you can move this thing up
and down you can hit this ball to move
to the other side and there's also a
flip symmetry
like this
over the image
okay
so again the the equivariance that we
would like to
enforce here is that if i have a
particular situation here and i have a
mirrored situation like this we apply to
the state some operator l
here we have some kind of policy network
so the policy is a function of s that
recommends an action right that
basically says you know
this says you know high probability move
to the left in order to balance the ball
right
and here um
the same thing for this one what we want
is that there is an action in this space
or a sort of a yeah and uh
an action of the of the group on this
space transformation on the policy here
that would then in this case
permute the two
uh
actions right so the policy here is
setting high probability on left and low
on right
the policy on this side the flip thing
should be high probability on right and
low probability on left right and we
want that this
diagram commute so first flipping
and then from you know and then
computing the policy
should be the same as
first computing the policy and then
flipping in this new space right and so
the action here is a very different
action than the action here because here
the action is actually a mirroring
of the pixels of the image where here
the action is a permutation of you know
the two dimensions of the policy
okay so uh basically in uh equations um
so i have a sa pair
and same policy so i have as a policy so
we're going to look at the polls i'm
going to train the policy
on state s
let me let me first go here so if i have
a policy on state s and i transform the
state which is going from here to here
that should be the same as
applying the policy
where it's going from here to here
and then transforming the policy which
is going from here to here right and
these two these two paths
should be the same
so that's ex that's explicitly
acquivariance right that's exactly
equivariance but now expressed in the
space of
state actions and policies
um
yeah okay so uh again going back to the
homomorphism so we here we have sort of
our orbits so that this the state
actions which are related through the
transformation to g the group action g
and here's the sort of mapping to the
abstract space
so we now want to create a policy
implemented as a deep neural network
to enforce this this this equivariance
are we really going to work in this
space now are we going to enforce this
idea that you know these two things are
related by this equivariance
relationship and so that's sort that's
similar to basically acting directly in
this space
um and you know we have we have a way to
to construct this in a very simple
straightforward manner i just want to
say that this is something that we did
in 2016 with taco cohan
it's basically called a group equivalent
convolutional network
so here the it's a neural network which
implements these these equivalent
convolutions and non-linearities
um
and you know the policy is this group
convolutional neural network
and it has the property that if i rotate
the input images
i will get the right transformation
permutation
of the of the actions or the policy
okay so now the some some results uh
well i don't know
here's the card poll example and
basically what you should take away from
these examples is that
if you make these policies equivalent
then indeed you need less data to train
so you can see that
the return rises faster during learning
so it does need to see less examples in
order to
something actually ends up being higher
um and the end again is pretty
significant if you just use these even
these simple symmetries
so the final step um that i want to take
you through
is this idea next we have a we have a
question yeah definitely
yeah that's precisely right
so as a as a theorist i'm trying to see
where potential gains are
is there any way i can see anything in
rates here because i mean it seems like
at best i get a factor of two in my uh
sample complexity
i mean i can just stuff to assess more
data right i mean is there any hope to
gain more than this like is there any
example where you think there would be a
non-trivial scaling is the in the number
of of group actions you're modding out
like in the exponent maybe or something
okay that is a question that is made a
little too hard because i do think that
you're right that um
you know if you mold out
let's say
um
okay let's put it this way so if it's a
discrete group then i i guess you can
just gain linearly in the number of
actions the number of group elements
because basically every time you have a
group element you'll fold the space
isn't that actually okay so every time
you have a symmetry you fold the space
in two
and so if you then another symmetry
you'll fold it again so wouldn't that
actually
scale quite nicely i'm not sure
the other thing is to say is that
um at some for continuous actions your
you'll
you know your friends is your
a circle to a point right so now all the
points of a circle basically all get
mapped to a single point so the space in
which you now operate gets gets quite
dramatically reduced in some sense
so i don't know how that translates to
rates i guess you're the theorist who
can figure this out but
um in practice certainly this this does
help a lot
i mean if i think in terms of data
i could just do
like so
yeah i could do data augmentation for
example right if i observed only one
left side of the of the card poles i
could just basically duplicate all this
stuff to have to the right and that
would have essentially the same effect
right
yeah so okay so let's say that uh that
in principle that's true
it turns actually out that data
augmentation
does not work as well as hard coding it
into the neural network so there is
it but that's probably not you know
another rate but it's certainly true
that the actually the two are synergetic
so
even if you have hard-coded
the sort of the symmetries in data
augmentation still helps a little bit
strangely
um
but um
yeah so so let's say that if you have uh
you know if you have one group element
then you know you can so for every point
you can replicate one other point if you
have two group elements
then for every point in principle you
can produce
four points well we have four points
right because you can let's say
translate to the right turns it to the
left first transit to the left then
prints to the right so you get sort of
four points now that you're adding to
the problem
now if you have
three group elements
i think this sort of scales
exponentially
right now you can sort of add
points yeah i i i mean okay from a
theoretical point of view the complexity
of the positive orthant and the entire
space are essentially the same in terms
of entropy so like even if you divide by
two to the n the size like if i fold it
you know and time
the number of dimensions i'm not gaining
really anything in terms of complexity
so i don't know i don't know where i
could like you know melt that out in
this example with a maybe with a
continuous one
and and can i ask a final question it's
about computation so the way i see this
you know when you see the difference
between
data augmentation say or i mean you're
just let's say the data is being
generated you don't even need to augment
it right so like i look at the card poll
i mean you play to the left you play to
the right then maybe you're like you
know tennis player and your left side is
a little stronger but it's okay you have
a decent right side and uh and uh you're
gonna be able to solve this game now
what you seem to be doing is enforcing
that this player plays perfectly
symmetrically
and so i was wondering if this you know
it's just like proper versus improper
learning have you encountered like
failure modes where enforcing this
constraint sort of
makes your computational problem where
you're actually trying to minimize your
risk a little more uh uh complex because
you're forced to go only through paths
that take you through this like you know
purely symmetric models where if you
allowed yourself to deviate from from
those once in a while then maybe you
would actually converge a bit faster to
some some optimum
that's an interesting thought it's it
has purely on on the optimization end
right so you so the idea that you if you
if you give yourself more dimensions to
optimize then the optimization would go
faster yeah but it's really yeah i'm i'm
really i mean i'm not saying anything
deep here it's just this like you know
proper versus improper learning that you
know people have observed you know
computational trade-offs pretty
significant computational trade-offs uh
on the regular basis yeah
i i'm not too familiar with proper
improper learning so but we haven't
observed
ourselves not
not in in rl but we have done a lot of
experiments with
equivariance sort of map to just
prediction models like deep neural
networks
i don't think we've ever seen that this
thing learns slower i mean you also of
course you have
a lot of you can just add the you know
feature maps at will right so you can
add degrees of freedom as you want so
it's it's not that you're limited in the
number of degrees of freedom but
you do force
weight sharing
and what the impact of that weight
sharing precisely is on
you know on the actual uh sort of
optimization problem now i i don't think
we've certainly not looked at that and i
don't know the answer to that question
one comment about what you uh we're
wondering um i guess
you could already think of a
convolutional neural network as
doing this as hard coding equivariance
like translation equivariance yeah
and that's i think pretty good idea
convolutional neural networks saves you
you know a lot as opposed to just like
having like a dense
uh
neural network like to turn images into
images or something
does that sort of make sense
but uh
yeah this is more
foreign that you actually want your
network to do and it's very unlikely
that you know during visit would like to
build a cnn if you need it
and uh i think it's just like your stuff
you know you have images you start from
this thing and here
it's it feels a bit more incremental
than uh than just you know saying okay
i'm going to start with images and i'm
going to like for some like you know
special filters in there first and then
and then go from this architecture here
it feels like
you know yeah it's just like little
tweaks at the end i don't know how to
extend the
the trade-offs of the cheetah it seems
that it's working well but
i can't perceive it as strongly again
right
now i guess continuous makes a huge
difference
one one way you can kind of think of it
heuristically is that like the the group
acts on your search space as well and
you're quoting out by the group action
so it's a kind of of a dimensionality
reduction really right like you would
expect the dimension of the search space
is going to be produced by the dimension
of its narrow orbit
um
i only have a single group then that's
only going to give you like a constant
decrease in the dimension
um
but what a single group
or a single uh
one
uh you know element group right because
this a group we can have many group
elements in it right
what i mean is that if if
if the symmetry group is fixed
but but what i wonder is could could in
this framework could you also treat
situations where the group
itself depends on the size of the input
so for instance i give you an input of
size n and you want to learn like a
symmetric function and n variables
um in that case you might expect that
the the
the scaling would would get better and
better as i get more to get gets large
yeah well that's sort of for the
symmetric group you mean for
permutations sure yeah yeah so certainly
right so the
graph neural networks precisely
implement that right so they they
precisely implement the
symmetry under permutations that you
know it doesn't matter how many input
points you have you'll implement
invariant or equivariant function
actually equivariant functions on the
permutation group
um that
and and that that are just fine with any
input size n
um and here i don't know yet um
yeah here i guess the group is fixed so
the size of the group is fixed for sure
yeah
okay let me maybe finish off i have a
few more slides and then we can maybe
continue the discussion
um so the last part is about multi-agent
systems
and in multi-agent systems the situation
is slightly different
in this case um so you can think of
let's say uh you know this is a traffic
situation and you want to you know
predict uh you know if there's traffic
lights here maybe
the traffic lights turning red or green
what we're going to consider here is
a joint
reward function so coordination in that
sense but we want local computation so
we want the
these nodes to locally compute
their actions
but coordinate through communication
between sort of the different agents
and
so again here we have so this is the
sort of
the situation i sort of discussed before
so we have
you know a a image you know um and then
we can rotate the image so you see that
not only you know
not only so the whole thing rotates
basically
there's a policy here
for the four actions that we can take at
these four corners of the road
then there's some kind of permutation if
we rotate this thing as a permutation
because now this action is going to
move here so this action is now going to
move there so one's going to do so
this this action this policy is going to
move here but it's also going to change
right because you know now the situation
also is rotated relative so the actual
policy itself is going to change too
right so now we're rotating and then
computing the policy should be the same
as first the policy and then permuting
um
and the way to solve this um is going to
be now using a graph neural network an
equivalent graph neural network
so
the input state s goes to an equivalent
graph neural network to produce the
policy phi so this is a distributed
computation there's basically a message
passing scheme between the nodes in the
graph so here here are the nodes in the
graph
and it has the property that if i
rotate the input
i will get you know the proper
transformation on my policy like here
um of course it is also equivalent on
the permutation of the of the labels of
these nodes but that's a different
different thing
let me quickly tell you a little bit
about graph neural networks
maybe just focus on this side here this
is normal
convolution which you can think of as
message passing
from your neighboring nodes to the
central node where each node can send a
different message or it has a different
matrix to multiply the feature value of
the neighboring
state you know to the central state and
then everything gets added
and for graph neural networks the number
of neighbors can be different and so you
will have to sort of use the same
function for each one of the neighbors
in order to maintain this property of
equivariance otherwise you know the
the result would change in the order in
which i would treat these nodes and of
course the graph
doesn't have a particular ordering
and even the number of nodes can differ
now the more general function
the more general way to write this is i
have some
feature states h and you know at the
nodes so h i and h j let's say
and i have some fixed features living on
an edge they go through some function if
it's a fixed function phi
to compute a message the message that
goes from i to j
then we are going to collect
all the messages that are flowing from
the neighbors into j which is sort of
the summing operation here in the middle
so we're summing all the messages going
into the to the central node
and then we have another fixed
function could be neural net that takes
in the message takes in the state
of now j you know plus some additional
fixed information that's living on a
node
again through some
function phi to produce
the next feature value t plus one and
then you iterate this process so that's
a graph neural net so what we've been
doing is to make this
graph neural net equivalent under
rotations
because that's what we need for the you
know for the over the rl problem so here
we have our little graph
on the graph we have
scalar information
and we have vector information
and what we want is that if we rotate
the graph so here's a rotated version of
the graph where this x4 flows all the
way down there to here
of course the vector rotates as expected
the scalar
features don't transform at all right so
that's a rotation of the graph
and we want that first filtering
you know filtering changes the positions
of the graph and the vectors on the
graph and the
scalar features
first filtering and then rotating should
be the same as first rotating and then
filtering
now here's more detail on this message
passing update
see i have a little bit of time so let
me just go through a little bit so
here's the message now the message not
only depends on the scalar features of
the neighbors but it also
depends on the distance of the positions
x i minus x j
that's clearly an invariant
and then we compute some velocity vector
which is a linear combination of two
vectors multiplied by scalars
we do an update
we collect the messages we do another
update on the node now this turns out to
be
i mean it's easy to see that this is a
equivalent because the only vector
quantities which are v and x i minus x j
are simple you know three dimensional
vectors that get multiplied and combined
with scalars so this thing is still a
vector after you do
that um now we've we've extended this
and i won't go into this you can you can
look up the papers here there's this
called se3 transformers which actually
something very similar that's being used
to for alpha fold as well this is the
later first terrible equivalent message
passing
um
it's based on spherical harmonics or
irreducible representations of the
rotation group so much higher order
representations
and sort of here's a nice sort of demo
of here's the graph um so these are
these things are
sphere you know functions on the sphere
and in some
bizarre way
you know they're visualized by
you know by these blobby natures i think
you know the actual value is sort of how
far it sticks out
and it changes because it's going
through through the neural network
layers as it's being processed
um and if you rotate this object
you know everything will precisely
rotate the way you would imagine it
should rotate right so this thing will
precisely rotate with the actual
three-dimensional object and that's
constructed that way it's not trivial
but it feels trivial but it's not
trivial to construct it that way
okay so then to conclude um so so i
should say that these are these things
are now the actual equivalent graph
neural networks right so this is this
object here which computes the policy
and therefore is equivalent
okay so to conclude
um
now we we exploit symmetries in
reinforcement learning and mdps um
because the agent
can then need fewer experiences or
interactions with the world or have to
collect less data and interactions with
the world to perform well
there is a nice relationship with older
theory which is on mdp homomorphisms
and it's basically that the homomorphism
is a equivalence class over the orbit of
the group
um
this is one of the first papers you know
on how to you know
connect equivariance with uh sort of
reinforcement learning
um
in the sort of distributed nature for
the sort of uh
for the multi-agent setting
we have a
sort of uh formalism that works with
these graph neural networks where we
compute locally but coordinate globally
so we have a global
reward function
but the agents compute locally what they
need to do
um and then i would say to reiterate the
relevance to this workshop perhaps is
that
in reinforcement learning there is this
you know is is a tool that is starting
to emerge
to learn
size right not just to have some kind of
you know fixed optimization tool that
you have to run again and again and
again
it's more like meta learning
where you
um you know you look at many problems in
the same family
you try to extract patterns
that you then use to search faster in
the next iteration of the problem
and what hasn't been done in my opinion
um is that you can use the tools of
equivariance and symmetries
to solve these problems faster if you if
you do this in this kind of meta
learning sense so in other words
you know if you want to solve this tsp
problem it should give you exactly the
same solution as if you would present
the cities in this rotated form so any
policy
that would guide you through picking the
next city should in fact be equivariant
and you know it's agri variant so if you
know one city is presented to you like
this and the other problem is present to
you like this you should really
you know
this this
policy should should learn that it's
actually trying to learn the same policy
but a transformed copy of it
and that's where i will end
thank you
all right thank you max uh are there any
questions
okay
um
hey um quick question so i have a
question about approximately covariance
so
whether i should think of it as a good
thing or a bad thing so here it seems
that since you're enforcing you know
strict uh
uh equivariance and that's what you're
implementing it feels like you know
maybe there would be a stability study
to near equivariance but it would be
thought as a
negative thing some departure from your
assumption and so you would maybe try to
show that in fact you are say robust to
slight deviation from this equality of
equivalence that is imposing on you
but uh
you know and angry yeah algebra is all
about equalities and you know love this
but uh i i'm not an algebraic and i love
inequalities instead and rather than
imposing equivariance i would like to
impose some sort of you know smoothness
along group actions okay and that's
something that could actually go way
beyond the exact orbit that you have i
could just say you know i'm sort of lip
shits in the group actions or something
if i have a continuous group so you know
if i do a small symmetry then i'm close
but if my symmetry
if i do a small group action i stay
close but if i do a large group action
i'm not that close so think of like
maybe like a six right so if i take the
number six and i start rotating it at
some point i'm not going to call it a
six anymore but close enough i still
want to call it a sixth so yeah are
there any studies
are there any ways is this framework
allowing me to accommodate this so yeah
it is
yeah there is that i think that you know
a lot can be done there but one way that
you can accommodate it is by
instead of forcing it
the way we do it here you can put a uh
a loss function
an equivariance loss function on the
problem so you can basically say i
believe
there's an approximate equivariance and
so i want you know the input
transformed and then filtered i want
that
to be penalized from
you know first filtering and then
transforming my
representation and i can choose the
penalty that i put on that
uh
violation
of that equality right and so by using
uh sort of regularization terms of that
kind you can certainly deal with
approximate um aquivariance
thank you
okay we have another question
uh i'm wondering about the uh
did we stop the speaker
yes no there was a question online as
well so oh okay um but you can go ahead
okay i was wondering about data
augmentation i guess in uh
when in just the classification setting
it's kind of
free to augment your data you don't have
to go gather new data but in in uh
rl like i can imagine like if you're
trying to train like a robot to pick
things up
you actually have to like have it
run on the you know the rotated like
stuff so so is data augmentation no
longer free in the
um in rl or is there still some way to
do it for kind of free
so i'm not an expert in rl but i think
once you have
you know the full
ex you know experience for one
input and you can sort of
you know in in
in silico make the transformations
and do your training
assuming that you can sort of you know
take the input but then you transform
the input under your group action and
you know transform all the other you
know
you know the actions as well
i think
okay let me think about that so
um
okay so that's for equivariance now for
yeah yeah i guess you're right so if you
if you would transform the input you
would have to go
not just through in sort of a
classification but you would have to go
through maybe even
an action right an action might actually
be quite expensive in that way and so
it's much better to
build it in as a constraint
rather than do the augmentation because
it's way more expensive yeah i think
that's right
okay thanks
yeah so i have a very simple question so
all this
sorry uh let's take the question from
soledad uh
okay thanks um um i have two questions
so the the first question is regarding
the group equivalent convolution
approach like versus the irreducible
representation approach would you say
that the first one makes sense when the
group is discrete because you have to do
an integral
and the second one is what you would use
for general groups
yeah so um i think
so the group equivalent is certainly
most appropriate for
um
for the for for a discrete group but you
can also do it for continuous group by
simply discretizing the group uh which
is of course not ideal because you'll be
approximate
um so it can actually be used for
continuous words people have done that
for a rotation group they've simply
discretized the angle
um
so the the irreducible
um you do need to the problem with the
irreducible ones is also that you do
need to know the representation theory
for that group
and i'm not sure it's always known right
it's so it's uh
although although there is quite nice
yeah so i guess you do really need to
know the the representation uh
uh theory for that group so so
yeah if the harmonic analysis isn't
completely worked out for your
particular group then you're a bit in
trouble there
and um other another question is would
you consider using uh constraints coming
from units uh from like dimensions like
say if you're doing some basic
simulation some constraints coming from
just doing computations that respect
units
is that something that people care about
what was this thing unit
units like if you have something some
some things that are like kilograms or
meters
and you want to have a prediction that
is an energy would you uh would you care
about making it so that if the model
respects the units is that something
that that people care about
well i haven't cared about it but it's
an interesting observation um so we
typically don't care about units and in
computing computer science but as a
physicist you would care about it um
so then
so so you could demand something like
um i want my predictions to be
equivariant under changing units
right so you can say if somebody else
decides to
use inches instead of centimeters
i still want my answer to make sense but
now you know in whatever you know
uh units you want at the output
and and make it and so in other words if
if you expect that in the future people
will change units you'd better make your
neural network equivalent against those
changes
if that never happens if everybody
agrees to use the same units you don't
have to do it but i agree you can
certainly you can certainly think about
units as a yeah as a
as as a way to make things equivalent
yeah
okay i think we'll have one more
question and then we'll
wrap up
um so i i
i was curious uh actually about your
answer to
a different question a little bit ago
you were talking about approximate
equivariance and you mentioned the
possibility of
uh of of of of penalizing
non-equivariance or uh or or
non-invariant what i'm wondering is do
you know of a way to do that that's
actually computationally efficient
because naively it seems like in order
to implement that kind of penalty your
cost fashion has to involve computing an
integral over the group orbits in order
to determine how much the function
deviates from its orbital average um and
it seems like that would be extremely
costly because you're doing an integral
in a high dimensional space
um it
is there a way to actually like do that
efficiently
i don't think you need an integral
actually because the idea is that um
let's see
[Music]
i mean you would have to do something
like data augmentation right sorry but
but you can sample that orbit i guess is
what i want to say right so
you can sort of sample points on the
orbit
and then enforce
you know basically do back propagation
and
in your back propagation make sure that
everything that is sort of sampled on an
orbit
um
satisfies or approximately satisfies
that equivalence loss function or where
the equivalence loss function gets
minimized
um and by sampling it i guess you don't
have to integrate over the orbit
that's sort of a practical way you can
sort of do it i think
thanks
all right well let's thank max again
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you take a coffee break and hear
from soledad next
all right bye-bye thank you
thanks so much
you